welcome back it's an historic day right
here in our new studio in the middle of
times square i have to say when i pulled
up this morning i've never been in times
square at 5 00 a.m me neither you can
hear all sorts of conversations of
people going around but even at 5 00 a.m
it feels electric you never party till 5
a.m not in times square i'm a big square
no i never have it feels very different
it was like broad it was like 12 noon
the lights are that bright that's like a
jolt of energy like having coffee
without i think so too i'm really
excited about this new chapter for all
of us as you see we've got a new home
we've got a new name cbs mornings
make sure you you reminded tony last
week people to change their dvr change
your dvr if you have the old name in
there it will not record and you won't
want reports
most of all we've got a new co-host what
your name is uh nate burleson nate
burlington around here we call him aka
nate the great his talent and his
tenacity on and off the football field
brought him to cbs news in may as a
guest host we were so impressed that we
said nate do you want to come and play
with us full time
yeah pretty pleases right and you said
yes oh you guys are so sweet if i wasn't
so chocolate you see me blushing right
now
he's an emmy award winner he's an nfl
veteran who played 11 seasons as a wide
receiver for the vikings the seahawks
and the lions in 2017 he joined cbs
sports as an analyst for nfl today
reporting on game days and super bowl
look at you and super bowl sunday and
he's no stranger to these early mornings
before waking up with us he was an
anchor
on good morning football that's on the
nfl network he's also a fan of
entertainment news this is where i see
him used to see him all the time 2019 he
joined the show extra extra as a
correspondent he's a husband this is
what i like best of all he's a husband
and he's a father of three i really like
that and a fun fact he's originally from
canada and as you can see for yourself
he's got signature style i have to say
nate for the first time i said to james
what is nate going to be wearing today
i'm going to keep it casual i'll spice
it up occasionally i got to keep up with
the tongue oh i like it i like it
i like it i like it i appreciate that
we're thrilled to have you good morning
football is a great show when i first
heard you were joining us i was like let
me check out this show yeah first of all
and what'd you find it's fantastic he's
a great broadcaster but also just a good
dude yeah on your last day growing men
were breaking up into tears thank peter
yeah and kyle they were missing you five
years of working together the waterworks
were flowing um so i'm thankful to my
good morning football crew hello
everybody and i'm also thankful for this
position i understand this right here
it's prime real estate and i am in a
privileged position to help inform
entertain and uplift the people that are
watching so nate were you nervous about
making the transition because i think
that when we were talking about you the
time you said and said boy he is really
really good and it's so much bigger i
think than football what you do for sure
were you i love sports you know i've
been playing sports since i was eight
years old and i've been working in tv
since 2014 when i retired but now at 40
years old a husband a father of three
the things that i talk about when i go
home they fit this morning show so it
was eventually going to happen um but i
i made sure that the next step was going
to be with the right family and cbs is
the right family well we first started
talking about this you said that you had
to pay attention to what you were paying
attention to and because this is what
you talk about the news when you go home
it made sense for you to come here yeah
i'm extremely blessed i get to work a
job in a space that i'm interested in
and all the things that i want to talk
about i'll be able to share that with
the world well let me tell you something
i think you got swagger i think you
bring a little something to us and i'm
really excited that you're here and very
excited that you said yes but we're not
the only ones who are excited there are
other people who are very excited who
are wishing nate well
really yep
it was super bowl of bus baby
it's your old quarterback from seattle
matt hasselbeck i'm excited to hear what
you have to say but really it's those
outfits i cannot wait to see the outfits
co-host of cbs mornings we can't wait to
wake up every day with you going to cbs
nate
son
what's your little bro cliff a-ro man
i'm out here on the west coast i'm gonna
wake up to catch that first show man
nate we miss you already here at the
good morning football breakfast table
good luck we know you're going to crush
it and gail keep some extra tissues
maybe some waterproof mascara nate makes
me cry laughing at least once a show
what's up this little bro this big bro
congrats your new job we love you we
proud of you and keep killing it we wish
you the best of luck and we are so proud
of you i didn't know you'd take
newsworthy to another level now you're
in news congratulations my brother nate
burlson i know you've been representing
your second home detroit with lying
blood to the fullest hey nate it's ron
rivera here you have a great story to
tell but you're also going to tell some
great stories as well mates pops just
want to call and say uh congratulations
with the new cbs position hey what's up
man matthew out here in l.a proud of you
man can't wait to watch you do your
thing it's hard to believe but we have
known each other for like 10 years now i
do have one piece of advice though
you're a rookie again so you're gonna
have to bring the donuts i want to thank
you for the positive impact you've had
on my family over the years
and i can't wait to see the impact naper
olsen has on the entire cbs family
across the country hey nate it's your
buddy boomer
out working hard getting ready for the
football season congratulations on the
new gig little message to gail and tony
they are getting a great teammate
congratulations son for joining cbs
mornings i am so proud of you i love you
[Music]
i don't like surprises but that one
really pulled at the heartstrings thank
you guys and thank you for everybody
involved all the producers behind the
scenes yeah a lot of producers i just
heard about it this morning i thought oh
that's a really good idea really good
supposed to be professional you guys are
going to make me lose it here but thank
you for that i know but you must feel
how many people are pulling for you
that's what i think is so nice there
isn't one person that said oh what's he
doing there everybody said it's so great
for you he's such a great addition to
the team so we're really psyched he's a
great broadcaster and as that video
shows he's a good dude too we're very
glad to have you nate i appreciate that
welcome thank you so much and i i
recognize that there are a long list of
men and women that have come before me
yeah so the standard is high and i will
do my best to uphold that standard and
raise the bar occasionally and nobody
will be coming after this is it it's a
lock now